por qué
[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález el
presidente de eeuu joe biden que cumple
100 días en su cargo 100 días al mando
de eeuu en el marco de una coyuntura muy
complicada como lo indica la tradición
política en ese país el mandatario dio
un discurso ante el pleno de las dos
cámaras del congreso para comentar sobre
los avances que ha habido en sus
políticas y también para explicar los
lineamientos para sus ambiciosos planes
en el siguiente informe les damos un
resumen de este discurso que tuvo lugar
ayer en washington
a filias ahora después de sólo 100 días
puedo informar a la nación que eeuu está
de nuevo en movimiento de nuevo berlín
para marcar sus primeros 100 días de
gobierno el presidente joe biden se
dirigió al congreso junto a él y por
primera vez en la historia de eeuu
dos mujeres ocuparon las dos sillas del
podio la vicepresidenta kamala harris y
la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes nancy pelosi maiden
destacó el éxito de su plan de
vacunación y llamó a los escépticos a
aplicarse la inyección maiden destacó
también su gestión económica de la
pandemia y prometió un plan familiar
para lo que subirá impuestos para
quienes ganen más de 400 mil dólares
la economía creo más de un millón 300
mil nuevos puestos de trabajo en 100
días 3
más puestos de trabajo en los primeros
100 días que cualquier presidente haya
registrado
el plan contempla garantizar la salud y
la educación como un derecho y no como
un privilegio el presidente
estadounidense instó además al congreso
a aprobar sus reformas migratorias a la
policía y por un mayor control de armas
tenemos que unirnos para reconstruir la
confianza entre las fuerzas del orden y
las personas a las que sirven para
erradicar el racismo sistémico en
nuestro sistema de justicia penal y
promulgar una reforma judicial en nombre
de georg floyd que ya fue aprobada por
la cámara en cuanto a la política
internacional destacó el compromiso de
eeuu contra el cambio climático y
destacó el fin de la presencia de las
tropas del país en afganistán antes de
terminar mencionó a rusia su rival
geopolítico y le avisó que habrá
consecuencias ante cualquier escalada de
las tensiones ya chinas le dijo que no
busque la confrontación aunque mantendrá
las tropas en la región indo pacífica
bueno como lo ven múltiples puntos
múltiples aspectos fueron analizados en
ese discurso relaciones internacionales
economía salud
la pandemia kobe 19 y pues bueno vamos a
analizar para eso hemos invitado a rosa
town ser ella ese periodista y analista
de política internacional y también de
política estadounidense se encuentra en
la ciudad de miami en el estado de
florida y también está con nosotros es
césar martínez gomáriz él es presidente
de más consulting group y él se
encuentra en la ciudad de los ángeles en
el estado de california les recuerdo que
ustedes también hacen parte de esta
conversación pueden dejar sus preguntas
y sus comentarios en las redes sociales
se las recuerdo
estamos en facebook y también no se
encuentran en instagram y twitter como
france24
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal la
etiqueta es numeral el debate efe 24
tenemos de hecho una encuesta publicada
por el área de internet de france 24
para que dejen sus opiniones
relacionadas por supuesto con este tema
del discurso del presidente de eeuu joe
biden pues ya tenemos el contexto y
tenemos a los invitados comenzó
preguntándole entonces rosa en la ciudad
de miami sus primeras impresiones sobre
este discurso del presidente joe biden
con motivo de su
primeros 100 días
pero las primeras impresiones es que han
sido unos 100 días fulminantes
culminantes de todos los logros yo diría
que ha sido excelente
las crisis que aborda que con las que ha
enfrentado son crisis como tú decías al
comienzo enormes no muy complicado una
crisis del cobi económica de la
democracia no olvidemos el asalto al
congreso y todo lo que hemos visto
aparte de otros temas como el cambio
climático el racismo el supremacismo
blanco en fin hay un montón de temas
sobre la mesa y por supuesto en la
creación en dentro de la economía la
economía el centro de todo esto no es la
creación de más puestos de trabajo que
es donde el presidente bailén está
enfocando todo su esfuerzo como él ha
dicho es una
su presidencia es a enfocar en la clase
media yo creo que ayer respondiendo a tu
pregunta pues fue básicamente un
panorama no de lo que va a ser su
presidencia enfocado en la clase media
enfocado en revitalizar la democracia en
reconstruir el país no sólo en la
infraestructura sino revitalizar también
la economía y reconstruir el liderazgo
internacional las relaciones
internacionales tan dañadas en los
cuatro años previos no influido en
multilateralismo así que todo este yo
creo que es un panorama genérico verdad
de lo que ocurrió ayer césar en la
ciudad de los ángeles en california sus
impresiones sobre este discurso
el tema yo lo vería en dos formas uno en
forma y otro en fondo en forma
regresamos a la normalidad al protocolo
a tener un evento en el cual no era de
estridencia o sorpresa sino de ver a un
presidente que está informándole al
congreso y al país que ha sucedido en
100 días también hay una presidenta y
una líder de la cámara baja entonces es
mucho en forma y también un baile en que
llega como presidente nuevamente que
dice estamos volviendo a crecer
estamos volviendo a inventar estamos
volviendo a descubrir recordemos que
este marte entonces y estamos viendo
dentro de una crisis una oportunidad yo
creo que muchos de estos discursos de lo
que se trata también es darle ánimo al
país decirles estamos de regreso eso lo
veo en cuanto a la forma en cuanto a
fondo pues básicamente es una una
propuesta muy al estilo enviar se es
restablecer la economía a reinyectar
de alguna manera decía pues aquellos con
mucho en pesos que tienen tanto dinero
van a tener que entregar un poquito más
de su gran fortuna para ayudar un poco
más a clases bajas a clases medias
entonces se convierte eso en un
excelente muy buenos 100 días
definitivamente y lo más importante ya
no tenemos nuevamente un discurso sobre
una sola persona sobre tron que para él
era todo rigor de separación y acerca de
él en este caso es unión no le estaban
haciendo mucho caso los republicanos
pero es unidad y que sean nuevamente
como país como los estados unidos
y agua ahora la ronda a la inversa
regreso con césar y luego pasó a rosa y
quiero ya empezar a profundizar en los
diferentes aspectos que tocó el
presidente en su discurso habló de los
logros alcanzados en términos de
vacunación ya vamos a analizar las
promesas que tanto puede llegar a hacer
en estos cuatro años 220 millones de
dosis de vacunas ya inoculadas entre los
estadounidenses muy por encima de esas
100 millones que había prometido para
los 100 millones
en los primeros 100 días 100 millones de
dosis también la invitación a que la
gente se vacune porque incluso los
indicadores están diciendo que hay
muchas personas que están viendo con
alguna suspicacia la vacunación entre
ellos algunos republicanos césar en
términos de la vacunación son el gran
abanderado a nivel internacional este
puede ser tal vez el aspecto que más se
pueda destacar del presidente va a tener
en estos 100 días
impresionante me regresaría forma y
fotos fondo hay vacunas hay suficientes
hay y en forma es nuevamente él dijo
vamos a abonar nos vemos que la misma
sesión fue constan a distancia con poca
gente sea como recordando si vamos
saliendo de la crisis pero aún estamos
ahí y de alguna manera vemos situaciones
como la de la india yo creo que un buen
detalle hacer que inclusive lo dijo el
presidente vamos a tener vacunas
disponibles entendiendo que primero van
los eeuu pero tenemos que ayudar al
mundo final de cuentas no vamos a estar
bien hasta que todos estemos bien pero
creo que eso es una manera de decir que
también el país requería una vacuna de
ley a quitar tanta división tanto odio
tanto personalismo yo creo que también
es esta vacuna de ánimo porque llevamos
un año dificilísimo y todavía vienen
tiempos difíciles pero esto es
nuevamente esos nuevos como ronald
reagan le hacía que animaba el país como
un etnia con sus fábricas de alguna
manera
a reactivarlos y recordando que la
vacunación si la vacuna si no hay salud
pues no tenemos nada entonces primordial
muy bueno que haya comenzado con eso
creo que hay consenso a nivel
internacional en que su tono en este
discurso fue bastante positivo tratando
de entregar a los estadounidenses una
energía recargada en medio de esta
coyuntura tan difícil rosa su opinión
sobre el tema de la vacunación sobre
este discurso en un tono mucho más
conciliador es mucho más positivo y
también le añado otro punto para
analizar el empleo un punto importante
allí 1 millón 300 mil empleos nuevos en
100 días y bueno estoy de acuerdo
primero con lo que está diciendo césar
es muy importante el cambio que hemos
visto de estilo así que hay que analizar
y dividir es mejor dicho separar el
estilo de la sustancia de lo que hizo el
presidente y es que efectivamente yo
creo que el estilo es muy muy importante
porque como que sienta el tono de todo
lo demás
byd en habla de una manera muy directa
muy sencilla que le llega muchísimo al
pueblo y que por supuesto es no no hable
en primera persona como decía césar es
decir no es él el que habla persona sino
que habla en primera persona del plural
muy importante porque no es no quiere
ser el protagonista sino que seamos
todos el protagonista en el país
entonces este es un cambio trascendental
que ha calmado diría yo mucho los ánimos
o sea yo lo que diría que el mayor
cambio que ha traído bailén es una paz
tremenda al país que antes estábamos
todo el día con un caos con una tensión
etcétera pero bueno no me desvío de tu
pregunta santiago
la vacunación era era el digamos en el
aspecto capital el aspecto fundamental
para poder llevar a cabo todos los demás
planes sí sí el país no está saludable
no se puede reactivar la economía es
decir es una especie de dominó para que
todas las piezas
vayan encajando sino si se si se tumba
la primera todas las demás se tumba no
entonces en este sentido yo creo que la
vacunación ha sido excelente está siendo
excelente 200 y pico millones de
vacunados bueno algunos todavía no de la
segunda pero pero es es un es un
extraordinario punto de partida es decir
hemos pasado de ser el peor país del
mundo con kobe el año pasado a ser el
mejor con la vacunación y esto es
extraordinario con respecto a tu
pregunta de los trabajos efectivamente
todo
como creo que comentaba en el preámbulo
no en la primera pregunta que nos has
hecho mostraba el trabajo y la creación
de empleo la creación de trabajos es el
el eje principal de toda la política de
vaivén para reactivar y para reactivar
la clase media eso conlleva también
también pues mejoras digamos el como se
decía también en el comienzo en la salud
hacerla un derecho a la educación porque
ha dado un montón también de ha dedicado
al destinado un montón de presupuesto a
la educación a la salud y no solamente
al kobe y a la reactivación en general
de toda la economía en medio de todo lo
cual y el enfoque son pues la creación
de trabajos y estamos viendo que por el
momento se ha reducido enormemente el
desempleo ya en estos primeros cien días
las reducciones de empleo y estamos a
niveles pre pandémicos esto es muy
importante
y también la proyección de que la
economía suba este año crezca perdón más
de un 6% del total del año estos son
datos económicos muy importantes y le da
la impresión por lo menos a los
ciudadanos estadounidenses que no toda
la atención se está enfocando en la
pandemia que sigue siendo un asunto
sumamente importante pero que todos los
otros aspectos de importancia en el país
están manteniéndose a flote a pesar de
la difícil coyuntura que está haciendo
frente a eeuu
césar este término este punto del empleo
es de suma importancia y eso va ligado
va encadenado con ese ambicioso plan de
infraestructura que quiere dar inicio el
presidente de byd en una renovación
total de las autopistas a los puertos
los aeropuertos los centros de logística
para poder hacer frente a la competencia
comercial voraz que tiene china ya en el
mundo entero la reactivación usted la ve
fácil ve esa esa generación de empleo
fácil ya hablamos ya decía rosa que hay
una
se vislumbran el panorama a un positivo
crecimiento de la economía
para veníamos de estar muy abajo todo lo
que empiece a subir va a ser muy
bienvenido y hay que recordar que
después de las crisis vayámonos cien
años atrás recuerden que esta pandemia
tremenda del 18 y 19 de 1918 y 19
vinieron luego los 20 me dieron esa con
digamos en los veintes puede ser que de
estas crisis podemos tener una
oportunidad pero también es el momento
de buscar cómo está china china lo que
he hecho es invertir invertir invertir
algunos lo verán como deuda pero el
presidente lo estuvo planteando vamos a
ver hasta donde le permite el congreso y
el senado llevar a este plan saben que
estos dos años es cuando pueden usar su
capital político no sabes tendrá el
congreso después pero ver esto oye
invierto y creo empleos entonces cómo
funciona volviendo a guam en su
estructura y en vez de estar programas
sociales digamos de dar mejor hago
generó empleo cientos pueden funcionar
esto y después de una pandemia una
actriz es la que tuvimos pues también si
es momento de endeudarse para nuevo
poder
recuperar algo pero anteriormente donald
trump piso
de una exención de impuestos a gente muy
rica y nos hemos dado cuenta que este
famoso truco urbano economics que la
economía de que si le quitas el impuesto
a los ricos le va a llegar a los pobres
a la clase media no ha funcionado si no
nos hemos dado cuenta inclusive que los
hijos de las compañías siguieron ganando
y ganando más mientras se perdieron casi
23 empleos impresionante entonces creo
que esta fórmula algunos la criticaran
que es demasiado ambiciosa pero parece
ser que hay que hacer lo bueno es que no
está pasivo no es un presidente
nuevamente yo yo yo es el presidente que
vamos a hacer ya lo diré el tiempo
veamos qué pasa el congreso pero por lo
menos como arranque de estos 100 días
como arranque sido el siguiente paso
para poder competir contra china a nivel
global y activar la economía puede ser
bueno reconstruir a eeuu desde lo
laboral y desde la clase media es una
frase textual de las que dijo anoche en
su discurso el presidente byte en tema
importantísimo para la región de américa
latina la migración
no pidió al congreso agilizar la
aprobación de algunas leyes para poder
aclarar la situación de cerca de 11
millones de emigrantes que están ya en
eeuu y volvió a incluir y volvió a hacer
un llamado al congreso para que los
dreamers puedan ya por fin tener un
estatus mucho más claro dentro de eeuu
rosa el tema migratorio sumamente
importante para los latinoamericanos su
opinión definitivamente sí y yo creo que
vaya bien es el mejor excedente para
abordar el tema la la reforma de la
inmigración que llevamos años y años y
años en que se habla mucho de la reforma
pero nunca se llega a hacer una reforma
correcta verdad entonces en estos
momentos en el que hay una crisis en la
frontera hay que llamarlo por su nombre
y yo creo que es el momento oportuno
para que el congreso porque el
presidente tiene tiene cierto poder pero
en realidad las leyes son del congreso
no entonces el congreso y es lo que hizo
ayer fue pues estimular el congreso y
emplazarle a que a que efectivamente
cartas sobre el asunto y haga una nueva
reforma de la ley de inmigración
ayer también mencionó que digamos que él
favorece está a favor de que las
personas que tienen el tps el temple no
sé cómo sienten española siempre hay
estados si se reserven un estatus por
las condiciones de sus países
hay que exacto pues que esas personas se
les abra en mencionó a ellos y a otros
más no pero que se abra una vía a que
puedan estar con documentación legal y
una vía hacia la residencia primero
residencia legal y la ciudadanía después
porque son personas en su inmensa
mayoría que están trabajando pagando
impuestos y que merecidamente por
supuesto tienen que se les tiene que
abrir una una oportunidad yo creo que el
congreso y como decía como viene en cien
césar él tiene dos años el presidente
tocó en un congreso que puede pasar
leyes
sin tener que acudir a sin que perdona
que a veces no me expreso bien en
español pero la pérdida de portón y
otras palabras que puede pasar leyes en
dos años porque tiene un congreso y un
senado que son demócratas son pequeña
mayoría pero todavía lo son pero es muy
probable que históricamente siempre
cambia el congreso a manos del otro
partido en los dos años obviamente es
algo que tanto la inmigración como los
trabajos como todas las reformas que
pretende hacer baile tiene que hacerlas
de pizza yo creo que por eso ha empezado
deprisa y creo que va a ser un
presidente transformador como lo fue el
franklin delano roosevelt
su opinión sobre este tema migratorio ya
incluso vemos que ha puesto en marcha
algunos planes específicos un encuentro
entre la vicepresidenta harris y el
presidente de guatemala alejandro
giammattei hay avances en esta materia
pero porque a eeuu le cuesta tanto
decidir en materia legislativa en el
área migratoria
pero vamos a entender que somos un país
de inmigrantes nos hemos hecho por los
inmigrantes
y qué sucede a mí me tocó trabajar
inclusive en el 2006-2007 cuando el
presidente bush ya estaba buscando esta
reforma migratoria no logró pasar su
mismo partido no lo permitió e inclusive
llorar cuando el senador mccain nos
decía pídanle por favor a la gente que
no marchen las calles que marchan en los
teléfonos en las carpas que nos llamen
porque a final de cuentas el congreso lo
que quiere es que haya que sus
representados nos pida ciertas leyes con
el senador mccain inclusive trabajamos
con el 2008 en su campaña presidencial
se jugó su capital por un tiempo o por
una reforma migratoria no sucedió
barack obama prometió en el 8 hace que
en cuanto fuera electo presentaría esta
reforma no sucedió en el 12 trató no 12
y sólo muy bueno la orden ejecutiva para
nuestro y mersch siempre será un tema
siempre será algo que fue causa fue
opiniones fuertes pero a final de
cuentas los inmigrantes hacen que los
eeuu tienen esa fuerza tenga esa
vitalidad ahora
halla muy distinto ahora también uno
provider está jugando su capital
político lo dijo desde el día uno pero
dos los trabajadores que durante la
pandemia jugaron se la jugaron por el
país mucho fueron estos trabajadores
esenciales esta gente que estaba
recogiendo los alimentos en los campos
es la gente que estaba en los
supermercados manejando el transporte
entonces existe una empatía interesante
el tiempo es corto hay que moverlo
rápido porque no pueden pasar otras
cosas pero si se iba hagan empleos pero
también esta gente que ha trabajado por
nosotros puede ser un buen momento para
pasarlo se necesitan 10 senadores
republicanos si no no sucede pero puede
lograrse y recordar también hay una
cuestión en los primeros a final de
cuentas la gente quiere ayudar a nuestra
inversa entonces que creo que es buen
momento lo decíamos me interesa
creamos este vaivén y va a ser un
presidente de transición y va a
convertirse en un presidente
transformador podría ser como el billete
como en sus momentos cuando hizo la
acción
para los derechos también de la
población afroamericana los derechos
civiles entonces es interesante se está
jugando su por si su capital política
fuerte y la migración puede ser una
fortaleza césar hago la ronda a la
inversa sigo con usted usted está
diciendo que se juega su capital
político y también se lo está jugando
con esta propuesta de ponerle más
impuestos ustedes lo mencionaba
anteriormente a las empresas y a las
personas que tienen unas mayores
posibilidades a nivel económico y
también a estos nuevos millonarios y
billonarios que han surgido en eeuu e
incluso en los años de pandemia esto que
tanto puede llegar a ser factible que
tanto puede llevarse a la realidad
porque no es una medida popular
no creo que nadie vaya a sentirse mal
porque en besos vaya a tener un poquito
menos de cientos de millones o miles de
millones parece que son estos
y se está hablando de gente que gana de
400 mil dólares anuales para arriba o
aquellos ricos que pueden financiar
entonces creo que al final de cuentas
mucho de esto va a votantes de trompe
mucho de este votante de tron que estaba
molesto que no le llegaban las cosas y
de alguna manera podemos cristos
política también está hablando con ellos
indonesia y este tipo de empleos no
necesariamente va a requerir estos
grados universitarios este tipo de
empleos que pueden llegar entonces como
que está buscando decir a la visión de
estar si alguien sale a defender hay en
pesos no creo que mucha gente vaya a
estar de ese lado del mar que hay que
defenderse a la clase media ya la clase
que no necesita hábitat más fue una
gente que perdió su empleo durante la
pandemia
rosa importante también he destacado en
ese discurso el plan de familia
educación de calidad y universal para
poder ser competitivos ante las las
adversidades que hay en a nivel mundial
china por ejemplo y otros países que
siguen marchando económicamente mucho
mejor que eeuu un acceso al cuidado
infantil accesible 12 semanas de
licencia familiar
créditos reducción en los precios de los
medicamentos porque es es increíble
pensar que eeuu con la capacidad
económica que tiene su sistema de salud
es sumamente costoso para los ciudadanos
y es completamente lejano a realidades
que uno ve en otros países como por
ejemplo los estados nórdicos que tienen
unos sistemas de bienestar muy bien
fundamentados y que funcionan muy bien
eeuu puede estar dando este primer paso
para lograr algo parecido como lo vio
usted
pero yo creo yo creo que es muy muy
importante quizá uno de los aspectos
centrales de lo que propuso ayer el
presidente porque la educación es clave
en eeuu y en cualquier país como sabemos
no entonces las ayudas a la educación
pueden marcar la diferencia en la vida
de muchísimas de muchísimos jóvenes no
dos años porque la educación como
sabemos creo que lo sabe todo el mundo
no es carísima en este país como también
lo es la sanidad entonces que los
jóvenes tengan dos años
gratis de college es muy muy importante
porque se les da un gran empujón para
poder seguir hacia adelante estudiando
después con becas o como sea no pero
esos dos años pueden ser algo clave y
también todas las ayudas previas como
para los instruidos más jóvenes no hay
infantiles
así que ese aspecto es importantísimo
como también lo es como bien decías el
de la sanidad el presidente por ejemplo
ayer mencionó cómo es posible que este
país
se paguen por las fármacos tres veces
más y yo creo que se quedó corto tres
veces más que en la mayoría de los
países siendo además que las
multinacionales
la mayoría son son de eeuu con lo cual
tiene todavía menos sentido así que
cualquier reforma para la sanidad y la
sanidad hacia mente porque también va a
ampliar el agua
obamacare no el sistema de obama care y
ayudas al a la compra de fármacos y otro
tipo de ayudas a la sanidad la yo creo
que eso es importantísimo de nuevo para
la clase media una mejor educación un
mejor acceso a la sanidad para los que
viven en este vivimos en este país
sabemos y hemos visto a lo largo de los
años
cuán importante puede ser todo esto para
una familia normal muy importante y lo
costoso que resulta para los
estadounidenses formarse en expresar sus
impresiones sobre este plan de familia
que propone el presidente bite
rosas hay que hay que invertir en la
gente yo creo que estábamos viendo que
donald trump estaba preocupado en la
inversión del stock market de la mercado
de valores el presidente no está
diciendo invertir a la gente y como dice
no sabían las gentes que vivimos que en
este sistema médico sabemos que todos lo
vivimos no todos vivimos el famoso
software que no todos vivimos en esas
inversiones pero todos vivimos en esta
parte de salud y también en la parte de
educación dos años antes
empezar se comunicó cuatro años
inviertes dos años al pri que no se
convierte en guardería sino empezar a
aprender algo nuevo y luego dos años en
el conviviente conexia decides es
interesantísimo porque es impresionante
que tenemos un país que tiene es desde
kindergarten a la que terminasen high
school gratis pero luego el costo de
universidades por directivo para muchas
gentes entonces para competir con china
para competir con indian para competir
con japón para competir por la unión
europea
necesitamos tener gente más preparada
entonces nuevamente yo creo que no solo
inversión en infraestructura
lo más importante es inversión en la
gente
ya para ir cerrando césar en temas de
materia internacional relaciones
internacionales de habló directamente a
china le hablo directamente a rusia a
corea del norte mantendrá las bases
activas en el pacífico que está en japón
en guam en filipinas e hizo un llamado
general como el panorama pero no
menciono américa latina
yo creo que hay es labor nuestra de
latinoamérica también de decir hoy aquí
estamos este es un mercado que debería
ser como la unión europea aprender de
ese ejemplo porque si no nunca va a
acabar este fenómeno migratorio eeuu
tienen que entender que a una bar la de
6 pies de aspe este 8 10 20 metros habrá
una escalera para lograr si hay hambre
si hay necesidades entonces yo creo que
necesita un plan marshall para
latinoamérica hay que ser honestos se ha
inventado todo lo demás se tiene que
construir a un mercado sensacional de
muchísimos potenciales clientes los eeuu
tienen que buscar a ver de esa forma
ahora recordemos que también dijo de
nosotros que eran los precisamente china
rusia corea a los autócratas y decir oye
tenemos que demostrar que la democracia
es la mejor mejor fuerza que puede tener
y los eeuu tiene que dar el ejemplo que
de su ejemplo sea no una fuerza sino la
fuerza de su ejemplo no que nos ayude a
transformar
rosa sus impresiones sobre este tema
bueno y estoy totalmente de acuerdo de
hecho lo iba a decir ahora así que bueno
lo digo con lo que cada vez me sano que
yo creo que en estos momentos el por qué
no abordó digamos no se dirigió no hablo
de latinoamérica tampoco hablo de europa
y solamente hablo de china y de i d y de
rusia porque porque son
rivales estratégicos en gel geopolítico
y geoestratégico geoeconómico etcétera
pero también y lo más fundamental es que
la la gran batalla de las próximas
décadas
va a ser entre la autocracia y la
democracia entonces tanto china con su
crecimiento económico básicamente está
diciendo está dando a entender que la
democracia es como dijo vaivén no
demasiado complicada hay demasiado que a
hablar que estar de acuerdo y se pierde
mucho tiempo mientras que los autócratas
pueden seguir adelante con sus
decisiones sin tener que contar con
nadie es bueno esa es una idea por
supuesto de china y de y de rusia
entonces aquí se está jugando lo
fundamental es la batalla entre la
democracia y la autocracia y yo creo que
todo lo que está haciendo bailén de
estimular
la economía y todo lo demás la educación
y todo lo que hemos hablado el programa
está enfocado a demostrar a revitalizar
la democracia de eeuu como no sé cómo
ciencia como empujón se diría que hacia
todas las democracias del mundo no como
ejemplo y estímulo pero como ejemplo y
estímulo hacia todas las democracias del
mundo ese que se cree una solidaridad
frente a las autocracias que son
verdaderamente la mayor amenaza para
todos además después de los hechos del 6
de enero cuando precisamente el
parlamento o el congreso fue atacado y
eso puso en entredicho generó muchísima
preocupación entre las democracias
porque estados unidos es el gran
estandarte de la libertad y la
democracia a nivel internacional y dejó
a otros países un poco en incertidumbre
sobre este tema para el cierre y para
los pocos minutos que nos quedan para
este programa qué tan fácil va a ser
llevar a cabo todas estas medidas y
estos planes teniendo la configuración
del congreso teniendo en cuenta las
elecciones de medio término comienzo por
césar
de 30 segundos
como rosas lo dijo muy bien se está
jugando el capital político tiene dos
años hay que jugar todo a ver qué sucede
pero dicen que pedir no el pobre se
proponer puede fortalecer ahora las
misiones no lo puede pasar él tiene que
hacerlo el congreso y nos toca a
nosotros llamar a los congresistas
llamar a los senadores y decir que
queremos o no queremos estar rosa su
turno 20 segundos bueno yo creo que va a
emplear y está empleando y ya un gran
capital político en agilizar en agilizar
el proceso transformador de este país
tan necesario después de 40 años de
política keynesiana en la economía por
cierto y que necesitábamos poner en
muchos aspectos así que yo creo que está
empleando capital político necesitará el
conflicto dentro de dos años pero creo
que va a ser transformador la cosa y
césar muchas gracias por este análisis
para nosotros aquí en france 24 para
nuestra teleaudiencia puede seguir
dejando sus comentarios en las redes
sociales muchas gracias por la sintonía
sigan con nosotros
[Música]